friends and colleagues all of a sudden
he looked at us treated us slightly
differently than they had months or
years before when we were working
together and never quite understood that
you said what's to a reporter how long
must it take before I cease to be known
as a spaceman why did you make that
comment I guess we all like to be
recognized not for one piece of
fireworks but for the ledger of our
daily work that was Neil Armstrong in a
rare TV interview with Ed Bradley on 60
minutes
Armstrong spent much of his life after
the moon landing shunning attention if
people had to praise he encouraged them
to appreciate all of his work and not
just the landing but his one small step
affected people around the world in
profound ways tens of thousands felt
compelled to write him personal letters
what is in those letters and the
responses is a fascinating piece of
American history revealing a lot about
Armstrong and us one thing that's really
great about about these letters is that
you never really know what you're going
to find Jim Hansen his Neil Armstrong's
official biographer he wrote the book
first man we need to fail down here so
we don't fail up there and consulted on
the movie that followed and if he had
stayed a test pilot he would have
continued to contribute an achieve for
the past three years Hansen has been
going through a vast treasure trove of
letters the new book he put together
dear Neil Armstrong won't be released
until the fall but we got an early look
at the source material it's kept at
Purdue alma mater of more astronauts
than any university including Armstrong
this storage room is not open to the
public
Tracy grim is the curator how many
correspondents are we talking about here
there's at least 70,000 pieces of paper
in just the fan mail section alone the
rest of this 450 some boxes are the rest
of Neil's
life really he's in these boxes he
really is
working with Grimm Hansen separated the
letters into categories but there is one
prevailing theme most of these letters
are not people giving him something it's
them asking him for something
yeah they ask him for everything I mean
autographs pictures you know there's one
woman in Italy asks for one of his socks
really it's kind of like holding up a
mirror to ourselves to our culture here
he had become this global icon stepping
onto another world first person to do
that some people thought he was like a
demigod that he had insights into the
universe that nobody else had and they
wanted him to share those secrets you
know never one to overstate his
accomplishments or claim more knowledge
than he had Armstrong didn't always
respond but sometimes he did like when
an environmentalist from Philadelphia
accused him of polluting the solar
system so this is someone writing saying
they're upset that they left things
behind on the moon mr. Nickerson here is
concerned about environmental
degradation and trash
Armstrong sent a long letter back and as
you can see from the second paragraph
NASA has taken all reasonable
precautions to avoid disrupting the
natural environment of the moon there's
a merchant in Turkey who Armstrong paid
for souvenirs in 1970 this is a guy
living in Turkey who sold Neil Armstrong
something when he was there visiting
didn't want to cash the check because it
was from Neil Armstrong but then wrote
Neil Armstrong to say can you send me
another cheque
so what Neil did is he sent a duplicate
check and he says keep either one for
yourself and cash the other and enclosed
as a photograph which we may find
preferable to the cheque in which case
you may feel free to destroy the second
check the volume of international
letters surprised Hansen specifically
the many complimentary letters from our
Cold War nemesis and one of the first
chapters you deal with is letters from
Soviets from Russia yeah who were
congratulating him that's right one
reason I wanted to do that chapter is
that there was kind of this idea that
the Soviets paid no attention to Apollo
11 and didn't believe it some of them
didn't or that there was no news of
Apollo 11s moon-landing for Soviet
citizens to even know about
but in the Armstrong correspondence you
see a lot of letters from not just
Soviet citizens but from the Eastern
Bloc countries and they were all and
that none of them were nasty there are
also many letters from kids some sweet
like this dinner invitation from a young
girl some heartbreaking including a 14
year old looking for an autograph his
mother attached a separate letter
telling Armstrong the boy didn't know it
but was terminally ill Armstrong whose
daughter died of cancer at just two
wrote back immediately Douglas wrote jus
that hearing from you would be the
happiest moment of his life perhaps it
was just two hours after your letter
arrived he fell sweetly and peacefully
asleep with the sweetest little smile on
his face not to awaken again on this
earth somewhere you have a new little
guardian angel who joins me in these
sentiments I'm not sure there's a letter
that's more poignant than that one Wow a
copy of that letter was buried with
Douglas Wow passed away and we should
mention it's just one of those moments
that it really is the most profound
letter that we saw there the store the
the storage room there we mentioned is
not open to the public but the public
can request access to the letters and
they'll bring him out and then they'll
show them to you it's one of the things
that that Purdue was intent on uninsured
and the Neil Armstrong was when he
donated all of this is that there would
be open access to it part of what first
man did for so many of us was open up
this notion that Neil Armstrong was
indeed a very private person and no one
very few people knew about his
two-year-old daughter and her death it
just wasn't part the history you're
right and and and how it affected him in
the movie last year in the book itself
then 13 years before that dealt a lot
with with his personal effects such a
humble figure as well we'll be right
back
you